we talked about dated horror film [ __ ]
yeah that was one that was one of the
biggest dated horror film things where
the zombie is run why is she a zombie
number two how the [ __ ] is she running
faster than when she has glass on her
feet glass on her feet three she thought
she could fly
if john mcclane and die hard could
[ __ ] fly
instead she chooses in five four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast uh
if you haven't listened to this podcast
before uh we talk about literally
anything and everything but today we are
gonna talk about one of my favorite
films of all time
one of the worst marvel films i've ever
seen in my
[ __ ] life to the point where usually
when i watch a film you know before we
do a review i watch it a couple of times
right and
you know first time is always the same
it's like just watch it for what it is
don't over analyze it just watch it
whatever second time you could be a
little more analytical if i like it that
much i'll watch it three times um
this one was rough yeah
this one was [ __ ]
rough man and i think like the biggest
and we're talking about um doctor
strange uh multiverse of madness
multiverse of madness which number one
to do a multiverse film is very very
difficult because it's a very
complicated subject unless we're talking
about uh everything everywhere all at
once which was fantastic fantastic um
this one was a [ __ ] show
yeah
um well you you saw it when it by you
waited for it to come out on disney plus
right yeah i waited because people said
it was trash and then
like for me
obviously like the if you know what
pandemic taught me the most was that the
movie going experience really does
enhance the film yeah right there's
absolutely no unless you have a lot of
money for you to create your own theater
but even then it's just different it's
different yeah the however they set up
the sound the huge screen the you know
the ambiance whatever that it is
watching film in the theater is an
experience that cannot be replicated at
home yeah having said that i still
wouldn't have liked it
but
you did you made the right choice for
this one
and uh as we're speaking right now it's
the it's the thor uh premiere day for
the public um
and i i don't want to see it opening
weekend anymore i used to be that guy
wednesday night if they do showing up to
opening nights yeah thursday nights you
know the last opening night i i went to
see
multiverse of madness
probably the worst experience in the
theater i've ever had in my life
because it's like
you know he there's some [ __ ] cameo
there's some like uh joked or whatever
and it's just
[ __ ]
and like people cheering and all that
stuff and i was like man you know what
like
i think because of the infinity war and
end game theater like
environment because that was
once in a generation experience
people are trying to replicate that in
the theaters now and they like scream
and [ __ ] cheer and i can't stand that
[ __ ] so i i got to see uh thor love and
thunder yeah um ahead of time yeah
tim took me to the
whatever the pre-screening or whatever
whatnot right great there's no
previews or anything like that you just
get to see the film straight up and i
want to tell you how bad i want to say
that a lot of people try to do stand-up
for the first time at that movie
they thought that they were [ __ ]
funny it's like
every time like every time they made a
joke they were trying so hard to get the
crowd to laugh and there was one guy
specifically there that kept on making
these random jokes and noises that
nobody [ __ ] laughed at wait so it was
this like an influencer's early
screening kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just and i just wanted to turn
around and just be like bro bro this
isn't like a class clown situation yeah
also too if nobody laughed at the first
six jokes number seven is not gonna hit
get the [ __ ] out of here are you
recording your own dvd commentary
[ __ ] like watching it too i
understand when you know when you're in
a theater full of other influencers or
people who just wanted to watch the film
there's gonna be cheering hooping
whatever especially marvel films yeah
i've just come to understand that yeah
this one guy though did not understand
that he was not funny he's just he's
like are you even talking about the same
movie right now
and it's so weird too i think people
were trying to wait for their moment to
make a joke at the film that they were
missing a lot of the jokes because you
know taika watiti albeit one we'll talk
about this when we watch when you watch
love and thunder as well yeah i wasn't a
big fan of uh ragnarok because i love
taika watiti but i felt like the jokes
were so incessant that it was hard for
me to get into the film
um but that was because that wasn't what
you were expecting exactly yeah and so
i was kind of like okay let me reframe
my mind and watch this because i knew it
was a taikawati film which i knew
beforehand too but i just felt like in
ragnarok it was a lot of jokes it's a
type of humor that i don't like which is
rambling right right right which is a
lot of i know a lot of people like watch
uh dave on fx i hate that type of humor
oh it just keeps going the scene is
extended because they're whether they're
what are you doing improv or whatever
and in the edit they're like yeah let's
keep it let's keep it going that's the
thing what that happened with ragnarok
they let these moments happen where it's
about to be a serious conversation and
all of a sudden chris who plays thor
obviously starts going on this random
just starts rambling these jokes for the
longest time they didn't do this with um
love and thunder they made the jokes
very purposeful straight to the point
[ __ ] hilarious okay so they tightened
it up they tightened it up which made it
so much better for me you know what i
mean and that's the same reason why i
don't like dave because it's just little
dicky going on this like it'll be jokes
like this if you haven't seen the show
he'll be like oh he's like oh i love
laundry detergent you know laundry turns
because it gets on your clothes
sometimes it's powdery maybe they think
it's come you know comes kind of weird
right and they'll just
[ __ ] it's like bro the joke is done move
the [ __ ] on right and that's why i
didn't like it but
going back to this film this film's hot
trash
speaking of expectations and when you're
walking into a multiverse movie well not
walking in you're in your living room um
what were your you try to set your
expectations so this is just coming at
me kind of thing or did you have a
ragnarok situation uh this film i didn't
expect anything at all right so
uh i'm not too well versed with doctor
strange right so i don't know about dr
strange i mean i'm a marvel fan but i'm
not a fanatic in that type of sense so i
don't exactly know who dr strange is
aside from the times in the comic books
where he would come in and save the day
right whether because it had to do with
magic and sorcery and whatever bad guy
had to do with magic and sorcery doctor
strange would come in he was one of
those comic book characters you looked
at like is he asian
like neymar like i thought he was asian
too they just casted us like a south
american dude for the name more movies
like all right then i was like i don't
know what he is or what he does but he
just all he does is you know he just
doesn't yes you know so i mean same the
most of what i know about doctor strange
was like the little bit i saw from the
spider-man cartoon maybe exactly you
know uh and then literally the mcu
movies yeah and they just had like these
chinese dishes so yeah okay
let's talk about that
so
in the first
movie what we noticed because we we
actually made a movie about it when you
called it doctor
yeah yeah yeah yeah like the this trope
of a white man who goes to asia to
become the master
you know at some asian [ __ ]
too from a bald white lady
it's just all kind of weird
appropriation or like rule bending like
yeah yeah yeah you know see look you
know do you know we didn't totally you
know do some racist [ __ ] if we cast an
asian man that would be racist yeah that
was their argument like
all right [ __ ] roundabout
[ __ ]
but
the i think a little bit of that
saltiness watching it on the screen
though
was that it was all eastern magic yeah
yeah yeah they're wearing [ __ ]
microbes yeah they're like monks right
all of that their architecture of their
whole like everywhere they go is like
eastern magic and this one they threw
that [ __ ] out the window
like
it was all like witchcraft kind of thing
or whatever and it's like okay fine it's
a new kind of magic doctor strange is
supposed to be this dope [ __ ]
sorcerer he can do both eastern and
western all right and then
it's like okay i'll i can get over
that stuff and then um
as it's going though i don't know
sometimes when i'm seeing it it's just
like
this it's probably the most corniest mcu
movie i've ever seen too yeah but then
we you attribute that to the director
sam raimi right
um sam raimi if you guys aren't familiar
uh spider-man one two and three the toby
maguire ones before that um
army of darkness uh evil dead i believe
those old 80s like
be cheap ass
horror flicks
like he has a style right like he he
even has it in in spider-man where he
does these
pov camera clips like if someone throws
a knife all of a sudden the cuts to
camera is the knife pov
right
now at the time like you you do that
it's stylistic or whatever but by the
time spider-man came out it's like you
had great technology yeah you had all
this budget but then it was like this is
his style
you know we get to a movie like
multiverse of madness and there's
amazing cgi right and then there are
moments that it looks lackluster we said
earlier it looked like this is obviously
a reshoot yeah
um
those are the parts that was really
jarring for me yeah but i was looking at
some of the cgi and there was moments
where i'm like this is really dope and
then i look at i was like this is really
shitty what is this [ __ ] it was the same
thing on and off yeah same thing with
like shane she had those moments too
yeah where it was like oh this is really
dope and then i went
this is really shitty yeah like where's
the why is it so inconsistent and then i
watched spider-man um
was it homecoming uh latest one no way
home no way home yeah and the cgi was
consistent throughout the consistent
yeah so what the [ __ ] is happening with
these films so like black panther
terrible cgi in moments very bad in
moments um especially that very last
fight in my mind terrible
um the thing is it's not like
they spent less money on a cheaper vfx
house therefore it looks cheaper or they
got a bad artist to do it no it's like
every artist has a level of skill
especially if you're doing
a hollywood film like a quality like
standard right but with vfx it's about
time
how much time do you have like to render
more layers render more perfected uh
lighting and effects and all of that it
takes time
like back black panther's case
apparently was a hard february release
date because black history month um and
then so they had a russian live stream
apparently that last shot at that last
fight scene was a reshoot and they shot
it in december
oh my god they had two months to finish
that so just to give people a little bit
of reference just because uh i only know
this because marielle was in production
for a lot of 3d arts and animation stuff
right like for example she used to work
for tim miller's company who did um love
death and robots love death and robots
deadpool 1 yeah
so i had no [ __ ] idea
how much work uh people who do cgi
how intense it is right and by the way
it's not as exciting as most people
think they're not it's not one person or
three people doing everything scene by
scene by scene like for example if you
see like a movie called like moana right
yeah there's a set cgi team that just
works on [ __ ] hair yeah
and a person who simulates the sun yes
someone who simulates the atmosphere the
water yeah each layer somebody else is
like engineering exactly and so you'll
see people like i forgot who i was
talking to because i was at the uh it
was frozen two yeah uh after party right
and it was super [ __ ] dope and i was
talking to one of the artists and he was
like yeah man like you know the work
that we do is really really hard he goes
do you see that part of the film the
part where the ice went like that he
goes that was me yeah that's all they
did you were working for 66 months right
yeah
it was [ __ ] crazy how much work they
had right imagine disney went hey you
have two months to do this [ __ ] that
dude that right yeah and then they give
but and so that's the problem we're
starting to see as the audience too you
can see great cgi and bad cgi
i'm just saying as an audience be fair
to these artists because it's really
hard to do yeah it's
at that point it's because of time but
spider-man is a huge property you
[ __ ] know they've been working on
that for the last six years yeah right
and so they're gonna have it tight and
[ __ ] but like a lot of these you know uh
first time like uh first opening films
or whatever like sometimes it seems a
little rough around the edges but even
big films like this one um
things happen like covet and then
there's had to be reshoots and so there
are scenes where it's just like looks
pretty rough around the edges that's
what happened to uh when we did a review
of raya and the last dragon right uh
that was all everybody was working from
home during covid yeah the entire movie
was a pandemic yes and it was very very
[ __ ] apparent um and that was my
critique of it not so much of the artist
it's just that's what pandemic did to
the film yeah you know like
working from home when it comes to stuff
like in production is very very [ __ ]
hard the like setting up meetings the
flow of work it's so difficult because
when you have to make on-the-fly
adjustments you have to call people up
and and do a group zoom meeting when in
person you just go hey by the way make
sure you do this yeah you know and then
you gotta all sit there schedule a time
to have a screening to look at your shot
yep and then and that all depends on
your [ __ ] internet connection uh
connection and all that [ __ ] yeah and
people were doing voice over work at
home for like like for example i forgot
who i saw that was doing voice over work
but it was behind the scenes for ryan
the last dragon right and they had to do
it in their closet with the laptop open
with the director with like blankets all
around like what kind of and the audio
in right in the last dragon was not that
great it gets inconsistent yes right
right
so like productions issues aside
uh
this this story
uh what we always do is just go through
the plot in wikipedia yeah and we just
talk about like remembering the scene
so
america chavez and a version of stephen
strange are chased by a demon in space
between universes which search
while searching for the book of vashanti
that strange is killed and chavez
accidentally creates a portal that
transports herself and strange's corpse
to earth 616. where that universe's
version of strange rescues chavez from
another demon with health from the
sorcerer's supreme wong
chavez explains that the beings are
hunting her because she has the power to
travel through the multiverse the film
opens and it's just like you know big
action scene it's in spanish and this
big squid monster is chasing her right
um it's all cgi and all the stuff and
they're all going for this book
before we continue my lovely genius
brain farts
this podcast is brought to you by better
help you guys know i love better help
and i'm going to keep on talking about
this lovely sponsor because it's helped
me so much and it can help you too for
those of you out there that do not focus
on your mental health because you think
it makes you look weak or you're just
shy there's nothing to worry about
better help is there for you how well
would you take care of your car if you
had to keep the same one your entire
life well that's how our brains work so
why don't you treat it the same way
there are plenty of ways to support a
healthy brain like learning a new
language or taking power naps there's
also better help and online therapy i've
been using better help for quite a while
and it helps me sorts out my thoughts
because you know being on social media
can be freaking rough mentally
emotionally and everything else and
having my therapist help me and walk me
through my problems and sessions have
been really really great better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's better h-e-l-p-com
genius as soon as i heard that it's like
the book that lets you do anything
was like uh lazy that's pretty damn lazy
it's [ __ ] lazy man yeah so that's
like that's already off the jump which
you know by the way there's like two
books in here right yes okay i wanted to
get to that
not only are two books story wise plot
wise there are like three macguffins
all these plot chasing points like where
they you know they have to go after i i
had no id like
i don't like it too when something as
powerful right like the book of ashanti
right and there's no real explanation to
why this thing is so dope it's like dude
that book right there is the [ __ ]
yeah spoiler alert it doesn't do [ __ ]
i will talk about that yeah we'll get
there that [ __ ] piss me off so bad
that's okay
all right
um so he's at a
this the strange we know uh basically
the monster
kills this other universe is strange and
um
this girl um
mexico chavez uh america chavez
[Laughter]
costa rica chavez
[Laughter]
you know the funny thing is i was
thinking when you said it i was like no
that's right
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry america
what the [ __ ] was i even bringing up
oh my gosh okay so okay she has the
power to jump through multiverses
and um
uh they get sucked in to into the marvel
universe we know earth616 that's what
it's called
and by the way it's explained uh
steven strange sees that as a dream and
he wakes up later it's explained that
all of our dreams are actually
connections to all their multiverses
that's a plot point
um then steven strange gets ready for a
wedding and it's for his
uh old flame rachel mcadams right
christine
now in the first movie
they had zero chemistry yes right i'm
glad it only makes sense that she's
moving on and you know marrying someone
else it was actually kind of like really
shitty what they did to her as an
actress like to give her this role as
this character and she didn't have [ __ ]
to do yeah it was pretty terrible
um
so in this one uh she's marrying someone
else and then um
a giant squid monster uh with big
eyeball attacks town uh
new york city he goes and saves the day
uh and then here's the weird thing about
his magic from what we've seen from the
past marvel films all of a sudden he
turns to the green lantern yeah like
what the [ __ ]
this is the thing too like
so if you know a little bit about doctor
strange right he is supposed i mean he's
not the sorcerer supreme in this world
right yeah but essentially he could be
and this the sorcerer this he is
supposed to be
the [ __ ]
and i'll tell you some of his magic in
this movie was a little shitty yeah i
think it was a little a lot less
imaginative than the last yeah they kind
of nerfed him yeah you know which was
like when i saw that fight scene i'm
like what is this [ __ ] dude
i think that's the point because he went
one-on-one with thanos right so it's
like um you know you got to make it
tough for them story-wise but then when
you take it that far in the previous
film
you know
like
i you know i i just really want to see
something like
because i i hate doing this but then you
know like we said it's kind of lazy like
to nerf a character to bring it back or
do something a lot less imaginative and
the reason why for me you know nerfing
his powers don't make sense in this film
is because you later on find out in the
film that this octopus squid [ __ ] right
is not even supposed to be that strong
it's
in placement of the person who placed
that monster there right because
so
why does this have to be such a
difficult battle you know what i mean
you know opening big cgi fight yeah i
guess you know and i think it set the
tone too because it was [ __ ] gross
that [ __ ] grows
of course you didn't yeah for me i you
know i i'm philosophic uh i can't see i
have a hard time watching finding dory
because of that octopus
holy [ __ ] that's like what's your
favorite horror film dude finding dory
no but um you set the tone at the level
of violence that they're going for um
dude when he poked the [ __ ] eyeball
out and pulled that [ __ ] out ripped out
yeah yeah that's that's that's one of
the most violent scenes in a disney mcu
oh [ __ ] i'm watching this on disney plus
right now yeah
um
then uh
so let's see it where are we in the plot
so this is after they had the the
octopus scene and she tells them that
she has the power to
jump multiverses
but she
can't control it
right it just happens when she's scared
and so
he
recognizes
that
these
i don't know the monsters are they're
witchcraft runes
so strange consults wanda maximoff for
help but realizes that she is
responsible for the attacks
after acquiring the darkhold and
becoming the scarlet witch maximoff
believes that controlling chavez's
powers will allow her to reunite with
billy and tommy the children she created
during her time in west view i'm gonna
hold it there
so
if you didn't see wanda vision you're
jumping into this theater like huh
exactly which is something that i
[ __ ] hate it's a bit problematic that
they expect so much from the audience
like you have a disney plus membership
right like you saw this one right so for
a lot of people who didn't watch wand
division they didn't understand what was
going on yeah they're like wait hold up
why is scarlet scarlet witch evil what
is her motive and so they kind of brush
past this whole thing because they're
like oh this is stuff that you should
have known which doesn't make sense
because she is the main antagonist in
the whole [ __ ] film off the jump yes
just
there's no background dude she's just
like by the way i'm evil yeah that's it
that's all we get
it's like
okay um
like i said it keeps going back to the
idea of it being lazy
if
you know in the past when it connects
films you you give some backstory so we
understand like even the first avengers
for those who didn't see the previous
films right explain to me how
avengers part which is part four of this
mcu or in part five at the time
made billions of dollars when the
previous ones didn't make that much that
means a lot of people saw this without
seeing the previous films yeah because
it was good enough to stand up on its
own by backing up the characters within
the characters within the story just
like captain america's yes captain
america does a really really good job
yeah to catch you up to the story
instead it was like i'm not here to
judge you for what you did in west view
and the audience might be like what
happened in west view
they're like what's where's westview
yeah what is this kind of thing now
like i said a lot of fans would be like
well then why are you watching it you
should have saw
i mean but you you can't expect that
much from an audience member you have to
present the
the story unfold on it and by the way
too it's not like one division was a
film
right it's on disney that means you
would have to have an account to have
watched that show it was not a film it
was a episodic series yeah and you'd
have to dedicate nine hours which a lot
of people didn't even get through the
damn show because it was so slow for
them right so they still wouldn't have
even gotten yeah you know
so it's just that part two already set
such a bad tone because it's one of the
things i really really disliked about
earlier marvel films where they would
expect the audience to know too much so
at the end of wanda vision though
um she's struggling
she's struggling at up with the idea
like oh my god what have i done like
throughout the series we're seeing
what is making an antagonistic character
you know out of her right why is she's
making these [ __ ] decisions and the
decision she makes you know creates the
antagonism in her right and then when
she realizes that on the last episode
she's coming to oh my god like i'm so
sorry and she runs away right to this
cabin now pick up back here it's just
yep i'm the bad guy yeah
yep like here i am now you give me
america i want her i've been responsible
i sent the monsters
oh you were responsible for this whole
time oh
even like the way they did the reveal
was so stupid it was like why don't you
just bring america here oh and and tell
you her name yeah
and then the whole [ __ ] the whole
garden or the apple tree forest like
turns into [ __ ] and it's all
whatever and then she's like bring me
america
and then
she tells him you have till tomorrow
he goes away and there's what was the
whole point of like spending all that
money with changing this whole reality
that's the thing too what was the point
of that to say
look my
my landscaping is evil as well
[Laughter]
there was there was absolutely nothing
to that point like for kids to be like
oh
that's the bad guy yeah i get it right
make it easy
but
it was i'm just that it's gonna come up
so that's what i was damn lazy yeah you
could have
it i don't see a problem in wanda
teaming up with doctor strange then
learning more about the magic that she's
inexperienced in because he's supposed
to be the [ __ ] and the more she learns
the more she caters to her desires to
see her sons then we see a gradual
progression where
when while they're working together the
story does a pincer movement into where
she makes a decision where she becomes
the antagonist yeah that could have
happened in the third [ __ ] act yeah
instead boom off the bat she's a bad guy
now it's a big chasing thing it's
not going back to where it this movie is
it's
uh the mcu's first horror movie yeah and
i think maybe that was it's a trope
right it was just here's the bad guy
killer with a knife and now we're all
running yeah and
that's just kind of what we saw go
through
i mean just it's
i will talk about it more as you know
especially when these later scenes come
on but
one of the things that
and listen i would say that it's
when you have like these huge budget
films with the huge production behind it
that has a huge label such as disney
yeah there's like this fear that disney
will step in and tell you to change a
lot of what can make a film really great
um however sam raimi is also responsible
for spider-man so
i couldn't really give him that excuse
on this one yeah and it for me when i
see films like this and you know sam
remy wants to do a take on this making
this a horror film hey go hard or
[ __ ] go home yeah right don't don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] foot around and it just
it's terrible it was just so dated you
know what i mean very dangerous
it just felt like somehow
this movie was made in the early 90s but
they had state-of-the-art you know cgi
and like imax cameras but this
the production
like
like if you take away the cgi but the
way it's edited and made filmed uh
composed
dated yes it's very super dated man yeah
and i'll i'll talk about it later on too
yeah yeah so
when strange refuses to surrender chavez
maximoff attacks kamartage which is the
base in uh
well not to bet i guess because yeah i
don't know where the [ __ ] yeah wherever
that was
um
killing many sorcerers
chavez accidentally transports herself
in strange to earth 383 while maximoff
uses the darkhold to dreamwalk taking
control of her earth 838 counterpart who
lives a suburban life with her own billy
and tommy a surviving sorceress
sacrifices herself to destroy the dark
hold and break the dream walk enraged
maximoff forces wong to lead her to
mount wondergore
the source of the darkhold's power to
re-establish the tree by the way i hate
all these names yeah i hate all these
names and this only adds to the thing of
just dated [ __ ] that's this is like the
stuff that they used to label in this in
like 70s comic books yeah right yeah
it's like did you go to mount monketuka
but
i think all of these things burke
created in that time the 70s though
right
um
it
it
okay so
they have this scene of this battle at
their temple thing um she breaks through
into somebody's mind and then
you know it does that [ __ ] thing
again like i don't know what it is with
marvel but these [ __ ] have bows
and arrows and cannons yeah like
firework cannons with dragon mouths
that's
the barrel
yeah
but then again okay so they shoot the
arrows and they've got magic behind them
but they're not like any faster it just
feels like you know i don't think you
guys would have had much of a problem
with guns either
yeah and two but once again it kind of
goes back into the whole idea of
this is i mean they kind of cut like the
last stronghold of magic right yeah and
their defense is just them putting up
their hands and they only protect a very
specific spot
not a whole shield that's generated yeah
like those type of things you guys
should go check out wakanda man they got
to figure it out
[Laughter]
i don't think your magic's cutting it
man you guys need some technology
get on to the [ __ ] 21st century bro
yeah yeah like when i saw that and i'm
like oh wait they're only
it only works for a specific spot that
they hold their hand they concentrate
and they concentrate like it's not like
a whole thing that's going on i'm like
this is supposed to be the last
stronghold of magic to save
everybody yeah and by the way i'm basing
this off of once again going back to
how amazing dr strange was before
fighting thanos toe-to-toe yeah and then
you see all this [ __ ] and which by the
way wong is supposed to be pretty
[ __ ] strong too yeah and they make
that fool of like a [ __ ] throughout
this whole film which i hate because i
love benedick yeah i mean him falling
off the cliff coming back up but then
ultimately not doing [ __ ] anything he
didn't do [ __ ] in that temple he got
tossed around a lot a lot
he got his ass like [ __ ] hand the
only thing he's good for it's which is
such an asian trope is that he's really
good at reading books and knowing things
the expositionist in this film yeah he
was the one that told wanda everything
she needed to know man and guided her
along the way so that was like the weird
thing like
um as i mentioned this was written by
the guy who used to work at rick and
morty like disney hired this guy because
he understands writing the multiverse
and the more that was in the back of my
head i was watching doctor strange as
rick and america chavez is morty
yeah that's [ __ ] funny dude so cause
um
they
when whenever america chavez freaks out
her powers come come out and then she
they travel somewhere i mean it's every
time there's doctor strange they have
that dope like [ __ ] cgi like travel
fest i love that [ __ ]
um it's very stylistic it lasts only two
minutes but um they end up um in this
like perfect new york right or not
perfect but it's just different it's
very vibrant all this stuff it's a
different universe very high tech very
fast fast forward yeah they and they lay
out the general rules or whatever
now instead of these two characters
really getting to know each other
they accidentally step on this button on
the ground and then it's like boom this
retail store
that reads your dreams for you
this might as well called it like
exposition r us or something i'm so glad
you brought that [ __ ] up because once
again we're gonna talk about how [ __ ]
lazy this is lazy that [ __ ]
first of all why why no because it's a
multiverse it's good it could have it
okay so cheap and lazy though in the
middle of the street out of nowhere yeah
there's just random technology in this
world that's place where you step on it
let me just give recollect all your [ __ ]
for you yeah boom in public in imax side
so everyone can see your biggest trauma
of your life
in new york city
oh my god are you kidding me
like i would be so scared to step
anywhere dude i stepped on the circle as
a video of my dad beating my ass don't
go to third grade
don't go back to 1993 please don't go to
the time i came in my pants in front of
that girl
you better watch where you're walking
now
like that was the thing too when it went
to that trauma and i was like hold on a
second if that's supposed to be
something that's very personal that you
see why the [ __ ] was doctor strange
allowed to see everything
he was just like oh by the way i saw you
naked
okay
so i mean like
that also that scene is has had became
another issue
and
not because it's so [ __ ] dumb but
because america's parents are lesbians
she has two moms
oh i didn't even notice that yeah and so
this is why i wasn't allowed to play in
a lot of countries but despite that this
movie made 900 million dollars dude
yeah imagine if they got those other
numbers because those countries were
like yeah gay no way
but like so in the middle east like that
kind of [ __ ] oh yeah like but you know
like i said living in america they have
every movie out there at the
anything that's okay they'll get it yeah
but they don't really need movie
theaters but
um yeah that was uh part of the the news
with that but didn't didn't seem to
affect at all with its numbers
let's see and then
while searching for help
strange and chavez are apprehended by
earth 838 sorcerer supreme
karl mordo
and brought before the illuminati a
group consisting of mordo peggy carter
black agar boltagon
maria rambo reed richards and charles
xavier
they explained that though through
reckless use of their universe's
darkhold in the attempt to defeat thanos
earth-838 strange triggered a universe
destroying incursion
after defeating thanos the illuminati
executed their strange to prevent him
from causing more harm
mordo believes that earth 616 is strange
is similarly dangerous but maximoff
reestablished her dreamwalk at mount
wondergore and arrives in her earth 8th
ranked counterparts body before they can
pass judgment she kills all of the
illuminati except mordo
whom
strange subdues before fleeing with
chavez the two escape with help from
earth 83 as counterpart of strange's
ex-fiance christine palmer a scientist
working with the illuminati
all right so
uh cameo
like supreme cameo of all cameos all at
once jim halpert appears yes my theater
went so crazy that i couldn't hear the
[ __ ] dialogue what they were saying
you know
i you know i just wanted to take it in
but then
the the problem was it wasn't like all
like 100 people were cheering and saying
stuff there was like five [ __ ] kids
who were just screaming their asses off
and were like
can i just say
this is this is one of the things that i
like i remember i just rolled my eyes so
[ __ ] hard
so you have
[ __ ] tuning fork bundabor whatever
the [ __ ] his name is right
who is
black black agar boltagon yeah black
bolt yeah black bolt whatever the [ __ ]
his name is right he's so powerful on a
whisper could kill anybody right so
right before they're trying to appease
to this new you know scarlet witch right
yeah then they go listen
what does jim halper do
he [ __ ] exposes his power to her what
the [ __ ] don't say [ __ ]
he goes listen this person right here if
they open their mouth you know what can
happen right she goes oh cool i'll close
this off what mouth right oh my god what
if what if like [ __ ] jim helper was
like hey you know what wanda you're
right let's go find your kids black bolt
why don't you lead the way
he's just like laughter
like let's go go go right anything right
which for me like
the reason why that also doesn't make
sense too right you have somebody like
scarlet witch which they know
this world they kind of set these
characters up the illuminati as being
very very cautious right and they'll do
whatever they can to protect this
universe but for some reason they see
this major threat who just destroyed
their whole fortress and just came in
and they tried to appease to her
emotions it's like you just killed dr
strange like it was nothing
yeah and then over here he's like let me
let me just talk to you and you know try
to rash like rationalize with you what
are you just what are the none of this
makes sense you just gave this huge
story about why you had to kill your
doctor strange what's the problem what's
holding you back with this crazy threat
coming at you right now she just
literally destroyed
all your [ __ ] platoon like they're
all dead they're all gone all the robots
whatever [ __ ] everything up and they
go let me take this moment to try to
rationalize with this person and by the
way the one thing that could kill you
let me tell you the secret
what the [ __ ]
man it was brutal though i mean for what
it was worth them coming in and then
like killing them immediately i don't
know if it was satisfying or just
uh what do you call it like
like
a really dead ejaculation yeah yeah yeah
oh my god that there that was it and
this try to watch
like first of all i thought it was
hilarious that [ __ ] fantastic four
[ __ ] was his face was what's the reid
richards reed richards was like gonna do
something all right rubber band man
and look what happens to me he's
dismantled of course that was going to
happen and so that's the other thing i
i'm not like appreciating when we talk
about nerfing and laziness
is that as powerful as they are
why do you nerf them with stupidity yeah
why did they have to be dumb
to lose you know
it's just pure [ __ ] nonsense dude
yeah and like also too
one of the greatest and once again we're
talking about nerfing characters right
charles xavier no matter how strong
scarlet witch is he is one of the most
powerful minds in marvel in like the in
the whole x-men universe yeah controls
magneto uh [ __ ] he
had a hard time with it but he
[ __ ] worked the phoenix which is
supposed to be one of the most powerful
beings in the universe yeah
and he got
[ __ ] up by scarlett was like nothing
yeah
i i
i mean you saw him becoming a when he
goes into her mind it's like a very
caring empathetic walking
you know charles xavier and they
brutally [ __ ] him up
and i get confused as to whether we're
supposed to enjoy that
or like it was just cruel
this is what this was like the example
of you know when they shut when scarlet
was shut his mouth
and then you know when uh professor x
got his neck snapped it's like oh you're
trying to make this into a horror film
right right yeah but it was just
there's no good lead up to it you're
right i mean in a classic horror film we
get to know all the [ __ ] kids and oh
you're not going to survive you see that
tension
you know but when we get to know the
characters despite their feelings we
don't want them to die
um when you introduce a character five
minutes ago and then you kill them all
who cares yeah who cares now you know
and that's why it's like this is like
rick and morty yeah
this happens in rick morty all the time
in a cartoon it's funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah cartoon is funny not watching
it live was like um i don't know this
weird cynical sense of humor you know
what by the way too and i do have to
mention this and somebody might have
something to say about this because you
guys are you know marvel fanatics like i
said i'm a marvel fan not a fanatic
i was already done with the whole movie
when she had the what's it called the
book of uh the dark holder the dark hole
she had the dark hole right and she goes
oh i could just travel through and then
control this woman's body and i could be
with these kids if you already had the
power to be to take over that scarlet
witch's body
and then just be with the kids yeah why
did you need america chavez in the first
place right so what the [ __ ] is that
everyone's so at this point in the film
um dr strange and america
or her
after the book of ashanti
um
let's see that um one
um
uh sorceress she
sacrifices her life
and stabs the book burns it up the
darkhold book right
and now because of that we're introduced
to this third
macguffin which is another copy of the
dark old book which happens to be this
temple which then becomes another
adventure
and i gotta say man i'm starting to get
really tired of these movies that turn
into indiana jones
[Laughter]
when there's way too many mcguffins yeah
like i'm watching indiana jones um the
last star wars episode nine that was an
indiana jones star wars yeah because
they kept finding new little
trinkets and mcguffins you know
in the past mcu the macguffins were
always the infinity stones which were
part of explain to the people what
mcguffin is the macguffin is like
an object in the film that drives the
plot forward that motivates our
our the characters in the film to be
chasing after this thing you know and
like i said so like for example in the
mcu it's the infinity stones every
character bad or good or after this it's
driving the platform which with whatever
happens to this thing
now like i said it's part of the
overarching
the arc of the entire story the mcguffin
to drive it forward and we watch our
characters grow
but you destroy darkhold and then
there's a copy of it and then you have a
another one then you learn there's
actually another copies of it in
different universes then the book of
vashanti is a big
deal too in the middle of it but
the third
um mcguffin which was actually the
macguffin from the start is america
chavez herself she is a mcgovern yes she
is what everyone's after as well because
everyone's after her powers
right
the problem with making a character a
macguffin
right actually there is no problem you
just have to do it well yeah like the
fifth element yeah yeah yeah she's the
mcguffin everyone's after she's the
fifth element uh what's her name
miller
[Music]
i see the film but yeah that's the great
example of a macguffin character a
personality you know that's a very
important part of the film america
chavez to me
didn't
feel like
she honestly didn't feel that important
yeah she could have been like a
like a rock yeah that allows you to
travel through through
it didn't have to be a person at all
she was just kind of there um now
we're also seeing at this point in the
film that
stephen strange has control issues he
always has to hold the knife right he
has to be in control and he's the one
making these decisions that's why
um
wanda the the other surgeon from the
first film both have gripes with him
because he was the one to make the
decision to give thanos a time stone
and they
you know blame him for causing the snap
you know essentially because he did this
whatever
and so
what i'm
you you're trying to see okay then how
does his character tie in with this
whole plot and with america as well
so let's see where we left off
strange chavez and palmer enter the
space between universes to find the book
of vishanti which is the antithesis to
the darkhold but maximoff appears and
destroys it
boom
after you're after the whole time
through this movie and it's just you
want to talk about something that really
pissed me off which already this film
had a lot
that right there
i just i was like i had a pause yeah
cause
i was in disbelief about how [ __ ]
useless that [ __ ] was and yeah because
they're like that book the bet that you
can do anything it grants you the power
to do anything and she just blasts it
once and then it burns
what was the whole point of going after
the book of vashanti
why why just make a digital copy of it
man i don't know what's up they're in
the universe i don't know
[ __ ] are you talking about this book
which apparently is so powerful it's
almost like a fable a myth it doesn't
even exist those that's unreal it's in
between it's the gateway in the gateways
of all the other multiverses and all
that it has its own special realm
apparently
it's not fireproof
it's not magic proof yeah for being a
magic book yeah
like
what is this [ __ ] dude um and that
the reason why that also irritated me
too was because as a as somebody who was
um
in the viewers seat i wanted to see what
strange was gonna do with this book i
wanted to see him [ __ ] [ __ ] up because
they nerfed him so hard i was like oh
that's why it's because he's going to
get the book of ashanti and then [ __ ]
some [ __ ] up he touches it it lights on
fire he just goes um
[Laughter]
but i mean
what it leads him to is to have to make
the decision to use the dark hold again
what the other
strange was killed for
um we'll get to that part
let's see
she then takes over chavez's mind using
her powers to send the others to an
incursion-destroyed universe
strange defeats the destroyed universe's
strange
god damn the way this is written who has
been corrupted by his universe's
darkhold
and uses it to dreamwalk into the body
of his deceased counterpart on earth 616
the first dead strange from the
beginning
with wong's help strange saves chavez
from maximoff as she tries to take
chavez's powers
and encourages chavez to use her
abilities
use her abilities i i do i also forgot
about this
so
just to rewind it back when we were
talking about the universe with the with
the really high-tech new york or
whatever so they had this moment right
where
maximoff
is chasing them through the tunnel
right
whack
that [ __ ] to me was so [ __ ] whack
here's why and we talked about dated
horror film [ __ ] yeah that was one that
was one of the biggest dated horror film
things where the zombie is running why
is she a zombie
number two how the [ __ ] is she running
faster than when she has glass on her
feet glass on her feet three she thought
she could fly
if john mcclane and die hard could
[ __ ] fly
instead she chooses to walk with broken
glass in her feet somehow faster than
them it's scarier david
it's scarier she's a witch i was
watching i was like just fly
please just fly
what are you doing yeah i mean and
you know
we made that halloween um skit um i
ain't afraid no ghosts yes and so we
watch some horror films to
like
basically educate ourselves learn in a
technical perspective watch it as
editors watch it as um as dps
and then when we started doing it it was
like oh these are [ __ ] tricks these
are the parlors these are editing tricks
yeah the jump scares and all that
and then that's when i started
differentiating between the horror
movies i like and don't like i hate jump
scares it's cheap to me yeah and that's
just an opinion but i love the real
tension filled films
there was some manufactured tension here
at the end of that hallway scene because
it slows down and then the water drops
slow down and then what happens
jump scare
that was so corny
it was so [ __ ] corny it was just that
was one of the corniest i was like oh so
this is where sam raimi wanted to make
it a horror film this whole scene right
here where she's walk running like a
zombie which
she's not a zombie yeah why would she do
this why is she not flying how's she
running fast with glass on her feet i
don't like none of this makes sense and
it's only so he could do this horrific
thing yeah which is so [ __ ] lazy
i mean like you could even see it
through how um at the she's fighting all
those ultron bots and when she comes out
i mean i you think it's blood it's just
robot oil yeah yeah yeah
she's got black oil all over it yeah and
i guess it's bloody looking but just to
make her look scary
i mean even the what-mouth thing too i
was like all right matrix yeah
[Music]
lazy
the i mean that that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
brutal that's where it was like that
felt so rick and morty when his head
yeah yeah
like when he was unraveling yeah that
[ __ ] too um
i mean
talk about nerfing
monica
not monica maria rambo who is this
universe's captain marvel
yo why is
white captain marvel [ __ ] stronger
than thanos yeah and black after marvel
[ __ ] weak as [ __ ]
i don't know
like they're putting in the writing yeah
she's dealing with her oppression
that's what makes her dude like the [ __ ]
was that [ __ ] seriously that the the
nerfing on it was
yeah why [ __ ]
white captain america female one just
kicking ass yeah she has no power she
has no power technically she has super
strength okay but not like captain
marvel also and the reason why that
doesn't make any sense too it's like
her physical attributes are strength
right same thing with rubber band man
and she unraveled the [ __ ] out of him
but for some reason the shield makes her
a tactic is so different now right like
i i don't know it's just all that [ __ ]
yeah it was
there's
you know i'll be honest to a point where
it's kind of nitpicky for us at this
point but then when it's not enjoyable
you can nitpick a lot more things yeah
yeah
right so
the doctor strange uh haunted house
thing
right did you like that fight scene the
one where they were fighting with no
musical notes no i'm sorry i didn't
i hated it
i thought it was some of the whitest
[ __ ] ever
because in infinity war though doctor
strange and thanos have a straight
dragon ball [ __ ]
dope ass like reality bending dude you
know magic
like energy fight do you know what that
[ __ ] was to me i was like why is
beethoven fighting mozart dude yeah
what the [ __ ] is this dude i feel like
this he made it for the composer he was
like dude have at it
i'll say he sees his
harp one single note that explodes the
whole thing i was like dog i could care
less about that fight scene for us for
for
everything we're we're talking about
there's actually a story where kevin
feige's biggest complaint to sam raimi
was it's too corny yes and they had a
lot of fights about cutting out the
cordiness
but then i think the the standing
argument san marini has was just just
let me have this
[Laughter]
just just let me have this corny that's
just how he makes this film at least
it's honest yeah you know like this is
but i don't understand why marvel even
gave him a chance you saw what he did
with the spider-man so it's like
what was the point of this like how did
you think that this was going to be good
you know i i think it could be the draw
of his name you know and seeing how it
went through his last one with superhero
films
like i i was hyped for it too it's like
oh [ __ ] sam raimi's in it and that is
gonna do it but
i'm seeing it like oh man you know like
there's amazing technology today that
you don't have to make it look like a
bee movie thriller yeah you know and
the best part of this film that i
enjoyed the [ __ ] most
was the undead doctor strange yeah when
he went to go over there to you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] up right because he decided to
dreamwalk which was obviously not
something that he's supposed to do but
this was his dead body yeah that is
forbidden yeah this was the eeriest
creepiest coolest thing right and the
way that the trailer was set up i
thought we were gonna see more of this
[ __ ] and it was only in the last 15
minutes of the film yeah but it was the
coolest part about it and if anything
else that was the most horror thing that
i saw right watching these spirits come
out and scream which was very creepy and
very eerie but the scene when they
attacked christine oh yes was a little
too
cheeseball yeah yeah yeah yeah where
she's fighting the camera lens classic
samurai amy old school [ __ ]
um
but yeah uh so
i got confused that first time i saw
that too i was like i don't understand
where they are
i think it's because that incursion idea
flew over my head but incursion is when
um two a person from another universe is
in another universe and influences too
much of it it causes one of the
universes or both to implode on each
other so he went into a universe that
had an incursion happen to it that's why
it was all [ __ ] funky and weird yeah
and then you know he has this dialogue
with himself and
this strange has is was also consumed by
the dark hold
you know and he made a [ __ ] ton of
mistakes and all that but then um
what strange is doing is he's trying to
go after that book still regardless
um
so they have that music fight and then
he throws him on a window dies very
violently
and
he figures that because he doesn't have
the book of ashanti
he's going to use the darkhold
and
um i guess uh
they they go and he he goes into that
dead body and then it has that whole
thing with the souls and such and then
they have the fight but
when it gets down to it they they figure
that
like
america he can't take america's powers
it's gonna kill her right
now i don't know where i missed it
but somehow there was some pep talk
where he says you can do it
she does it she can control her powers
but when did she learn
because she her whole thing was
i don't know how to use it
right i don't get it right if the if
then there was a whole story about
teenage angst and um fighting through
your fears and taking up courage and
bravery i get it i understand it but no
she's just like i'll do it yeah and when
in the [ __ ] was her powers being able to
punch the [ __ ] out of somebody i thought
it was just that she could just travel
yeah all of a sudden she just starts
socking people like it just these powers
became a bit undefined i mean she
punches stars
and also too like the really confusing
part was right wang
is you know obviously he's the guy who
has all this knowledge he's a sorcerer
supreme yeah he knows
that there's this place that exists
right that darkhold is a copy the real
copy is written on the walls of this
temple of this temple nobody has ever
made it out alive she shows up and she
goes
this isn't the trap this is my throne
why
how cuz she's the botch boss [ __ ] yeah
like that was her boss [ __ ] moment i'm
like
where do you sit down
it was just this this korean uh
floorboard where you sleep i was i was
thinking like oh um i thought she was
gonna say it's an altar you know or
something like that something dark
witchcrafty or some [ __ ] but it was
that's her throne
cool
there was too many moments where i was
asking why
why i thought this place everybody who
has tried to go there [ __ ] died but
she just she shows up is it because
she's so powerful she's not a scarlet
witch so she was she in the dark that
was explained in wanda vision that's
what i'm saying like you gotta bring
that [ __ ] you know into this story too
you got to complete it like bring it
around circle if you're referencing the
past film instead you're just supposed
to know this [ __ ] just see i don't even
remember that from one division yeah
it's just happening it's just happening
yeah that's why for me as an audience
once again it was so confusing because i
don't remember because i mean when did i
watch one division that was why it was
the beginning of pandemic yeah that was
so long ago it was like two years ago
i'm not gonna remember this [ __ ] that's
why i didn't understand why when she
showed up they're just like dude my
master and she was like yeah
oh
okay
what is this muriel saw this film she
was pissed she was i don't understand
anything um by the way there was like a
talking yak
i don't remember that yak from the first
movie yeah i'm like what is this yellow
ox like just talking it has a voice and
everything i don't know
um
so yeah she just figures out her powers
and what she does is i'll give you what
you want right and
she transports maximoff back to earth
838
uh where she sees billy and tommy recoil
from her
her in fear while crying for their real
mother realizing that her of her ways
maximoff relents and uses her powers to
bring down mount wondergore
simultaneously destroying all copies of
the darkhold throughout the multiverse
and apparently sacrificing herself in
the process chavez returns strange and
palmer to their respective universes
some time later kamartage is repaired
and the surviving sorcerers and joined
by chavez continue training
strange develops a third eye as a result
of using the darkhold and dreamwalking
in into a corpse
in a mid-credits scene strange is
approached by a structurist who warns
him that his actions have triggered an
incursion that he must help fix
strange follows her into the dark
dimension
the end
all right
and then that one kid who was screaming
the whole time was just like
slow clapping
what the [ __ ] are you slow clapping for
you jackass i hated how it ended
he's walking down the street his theme's
playing and he
third eye credits
and then it cuts to he's walking down
the street again
the third eye comes back oh i guess it
doesn't hurt anymore yeah
that's what i'm saying like better
there's so many inconsistencies things
just don't make sense and once again
the the film if you guys watch it and
that's good i watched it twice painfully
and
it was just
it was like watching somebody just
trying to push a square into a circle
hole right right things just weren't
fitting and they were trying to force it
so hard with the corniness with the
horror theme the dialogue everything
about it seemed so forced and nothing
came together there was no reason for me
to care about the characters there was
no reason for me to give a [ __ ] about
the villain nothing there was no reason
for me to care at all you know care
about another universe that's destroyed
yeah
and for me too it's like is was this
really a multiverse film that i watched
it really wasn't but it's too bad for us
we saw everything everywhere all at once
first
[Laughter]
the most multiverse thing that i saw was
when they did that sequence where they
were traveling through all these
different multiverses that was the best
thing and then like i'm stuck there
pausing because i want to see what's up
and see the interesting stuff and then
i'm realizing but in a real theater
experience it just
comes and goes
um and i start really started thinking
about the way
i guess this marvel studios is is
treating their audience it's just they
feel like yeah of course they saw one
division they're gonna get it
yeah like giving the audience that
benefit of the doubt i think you're
giving them way too much credit
especially because it was two [ __ ]
years ago yeah yeah it was quite a while
ago and like two like
one thing that i also didn't like and
once again i think i'm being really
nitpicky because just off the jump the
film gave me such a bad taste in my
mouth was that you know
strange is also a really snarky
character yes
there's moments for him to be really
really funny and he only had one really
moment when he was talking to the
illuminati so there wasn't even like a
humor factor to this like there normally
is yeah like he doesn't have the same
charm as that tony yeah no charm
whatsoever he comes off as that doctor
you don't want to be your personal
physician yeah yeah yeah
douche don't touch me you know
and but he's like usually very humorous
like he's very smart very witty all that
other stuff and it just wasn't in that
film either so you know when they do
that to like main characters and they
don't give you a reason to really like
them
it's just like i mean i guess he did
have like redeeming moments where in his
his version his universe is doctor
strange he gave
america chavez a chance yeah kill
you know that's how i felt about the
whole film all right cool yeah i guess
i mean look at the third act of the
fifth element
where
um
you know lilu what where they had to
bring her into you know having to able
to access her powers and what was what
it was or whatever and
um ultimately like
it was the love that she had with bruce
willis character corbin dallas
right but we saw that develop and build
over time this [ __ ]
you know dirty-ass rat taxi driver yeah
you know getting into the situation
where their relationship grows and it
and it means something by that third act
like i said if you make a character a
macguffin they have to
have a strong connection and like
this doctor strange and her it was just
they it just felt like they pierced
acquaintances the other reason why this
wasn't really a good multiverse film how
many [ __ ] universes did we go into in
this film
three three
three
and then like a couple like middle
dimensions yeah right so that mount one
decor is apparently another dimension
somewhere oh i had no idea yeah yeah um
and
what the book of ashanti whatever it's
like these spaces between universes like
they could have had so much fun creating
multiple universes that they had to
travel in and figure out what i was
expecting i was expecting us to
see the act well we tried when we did
see them all together like as illuminati
but i was expecting them to go through
different universes
in that way
but you know at this point because
if that feels too ridiculous i honestly
now expect to see that in deadpool 3. um
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah how i feel
like we're gonna have to see it
to have to make it a meta version of
itself to link the fox x-men people with
the
disney and all that [ __ ] yeah i just
didn't understand how this was a
multiverse film like when you have that
title multiverse in it i better see
multiple universe and done really well
yeah you know because it
you're setting this up for [ __ ]
failure yeah like you're setting
yourself up for failure especially as an
audience when you kind of put that
expectation on us and then we see this
like what the [ __ ] is this but not just
multiverse the multiverse of madness
yeah then i'm expecting some [ __ ]
that crazy [ __ ] yeah
and uh it was yeah just a couple a
couple different universes which wasn't
even that crazy like the craziest thing
was what oh when you go to the stoplight
red means go and then
stop oh that's the that's the crazy [ __ ]
yeah
pizza comes in meatballs okay
[Laughter]
i'm seeing the laziest [ __ ] film ever
and that was that was the rick and morty
[ __ ] yeah you know that like that stuff
as a cartoon as a like come and go like
uh like a little bit
i guess it would work
but
um i
feel very
let down let's say as an audience member
when
it just feels like it could have been a
rick and morty movie instead in terms of
like marvel films what do you rank this
as from best to worst is this like one
of the worst you've seen yeah i'm gonna
say bottom five again yeah this is this
is
just to a
this film was way worse than shang chi
yeah yeah no shanghai was a much like i
gave shane like a five six yeah this
shit's like a one to me really i would
say like yeah for me four or five i
didn't know this was like well maybe
it's because once again like i don't
remember much from one division so it
was so confusing for me yeah and that
alone already makes me hate it just
makes a a bad film yeah
it was just
what is going on that's what i kept on
that and then i was like oh that's right
from this part and i hate having to do
that yeah i hate having to just excavate
all these old thoughts just so i could
figure out what the plot of this film is
and it's just it's also just not fair to
the viewer right and if people are
saying well well only marvel fans should
watch this that's the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard in my life no way
yeah
how else could a film be successful if
you're only catering to one type of
audience it doesn't make any sense
marvel films are supposed to be
enjoyable for everybody yeah and we've
talked about this too where sometimes as
an audience member you can be very lazy
too because you just expect people to
know things that you already know
because you're a fanatic yeah but this
is still a film at the end of the day
films would be graded with the way or
not graded i say films should be viewed
the way that film viewers just expect it
to be like just because it's a marvel
film it doesn't
you don't get a pass on it like for
example and this is what i mean by
sometimes people are on the um they're
on two sides of the fence about
something that doesn't make any sense
people got really upset at steven
spielberg when he said that marvel films
aren't films and then uh martin scorsese
martin scorsese
yeah martin scorsese
and they're like oh my god how can you
say it's not a film baba button that you
know people started you know ripping
into martin scorsese but when people
critique marvel films they go oh it's
not that type of film yeah which f what
is it then yeah
which one is it like i i got i got those
kind of messages too people telling me
like you're not supposed to look that
deep into it yes you are yes you are why
did they make like all the other films
in the past then you know
it's that's where i feel like marvel
phase four seems like it's going awry
and by the way too that's hyper
offensive to the comic book writers they
put a lot of thought and time into this
[ __ ] it's just not easy you know yeah
and sometimes these films [ __ ] up the
comic book writers stories yeah and this
is where they have a lot of problems
because obviously once again you're
talking about 300 comic books
break into an hour and a half two hours
so it's very very difficult right i
understand that but to say that you can
be mad at martin scorsese for saying
that these aren't films but at the same
time when somebody could take these
films you go it's not a real film anyway
what are you talking about yeah
that's nonsense that's pure nonsense
these are real films and there have been
great examples of it and we've talked
about uh you gave a lot of examples on
your instagram stories about you know
the overarching theme and the morality
be behind a lot of these marvel films
yeah i mean um even like
like the x-men
right when was it made in the 60s what
was happening in the 60s the civil
rights movement the mutants at the time
were representative of civil rights and
their stories were them going to the
senators and fighting with congress over
their rights as humans you know even
though they have mutations right it was
a reflection of what was happening in
america in that day professor x is
martin luther king
right magneto is malcolm x no dude he's
a comic book bro
they have the same goals
but then the other one is like by any
means necessary what do you [ __ ]
think captain america was based off of
you jackasses it's not political the
first comic book he's in is punching it
off hitler in your face what the [ __ ]
are you talking about but this is why
the comic books were were so popular it
was about real [ __ ] people connected to
these characters and these topics yeah
so i mean
when we get into these parts with like
oh it's multiverse it's all wacky it's
madness right and then we don't get into
the human experience that america chavez
is experiencing the character arc and
growth
but okay so because you let america do
her thing
your narcissism is under control now you
know your control issues are under
control now you know like the idea that
you always have to hold the knife they
made it so simple like yeah
like where did she build the courage
where did she get her bravery where did
she how did she come to where's the
emotional connection that he had with
[ __ ] america
yeah that made him go i actually value
your life now yeah where
he just there's no this payoff sucks so
bad he just looks at her and he just
goes
hey man do your thing
this zombie-ass face like you know what
is this man yeah
you're kind of wondering like what the
[ __ ] doctor strange
might be doing right with all the [ __ ]
that's been happening in marvel phase
four and
why that's why i think marvel face four
hasn't been doing so great
dude
you said you didn't fish finish the
eternals right no i could not do you
want me to just ruin it for you right
yeah go ahead i don't care i don't plan
to watch it there's a giant [ __ ]
celestial you know what celestia is
those big [ __ ] things yeah yeah yeah
it comes out of the earth
and this big hand comes out in the head
and if it when it fully burns out of the
earth it'll blow up and destroy the
earth right and they stop it like
gemma chan
turns it into this big marble statue
and now this earth has a [ __ ] giant
hand and head and body parts coming out
of the earth
so why isn't dr strange being like yo i
better investigate this [ __ ] yeah yeah
you know even wong let's say sorcerer
supreme yo uh this is your job now
you know uh there's like so many things
like what are we dealing with right now
guys yeah
why did you make eternals with this
huge threat going on and then just
completely forget about it in the next
one eternals did not need to be a film
it didn't it 100 didn't need to be a
film i i literally shut that [ __ ] off
because it reminded me of ryan the last
dragon too much [ __ ] right that had to
be explained within like an hour and a
half yeah couldn't do it you cannot do
it you cannot have that many characters
that many realms that many whatever that
much backstory that much history jumping
thousands of years in between with
people who clearly have like a modern
accent and they're living you know 5 000
years ago it's like what the [ __ ] is
this like the casting was all weird it
was a waste so that's so
okay that's what i'm that's welcome to
the 21st century
while um so top gun maverick right the
new one um in the first one it's just
like probably one of the whitest movies
ever made
right and the whole team the whole top
gun class just these douchebag white
dudes ripped and oily and sweaty and
naked all the time
and this new one
you have the
colors of the rainbow
asian kids black kids latino girl white
dudes and everyone it's like very
inclusive right
and then so looking at the eternals it
was just like yeah like everyone the hey
everyone is represented thing and
while it has its merits right
representation matters
the manufacturer force feeding of that
is really hard to swallow even for me an
advocate for
you know for uh representation um it it
feels like i'm watching the boys make
fun of the mcu yeah yeah yeah it looks
like a satire mcu movie when i'm
watching it not only that i was a little
shocked to see them have a full sex
scene in the beginning of that movie oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah
but then again i mean uh tony stark got
laid a lot in his first film too oh
that's true i think people forget that i
think yeah the internals too just by the
way i was on a plane ride to to a if you
can't watch a film through a plane that
means it's pretty [ __ ] bad yeah like
you're forced to sit there yeah and you
turn it off then it's bad i just was
like this is this is so [ __ ] whack or
whatever and it was just like
sometimes you have to like
what is it uh
disbelief you have to [ __ ] what do
you suspend your house by disband yes
suspend your disbelief when you watch a
lot of these like comic book films right
right it was really really hard with
this one because you're trying to
explain how these omnipotent human
beings who are here to protect earth
just let [ __ ] happen yeah for the last 7
thousand years yeah there's like oh you
know how the whole thanos thing's like
yeah i'm just gonna watch it yeah
what the [ __ ]
yeah the the character motivations too
like why they're doing what they're
doing because they were supposed to go
forward with it but because they saw
resilience in humans they want to keep
them alive or some [ __ ] like that but
it's like
you know the the problem being like they
it just
feels like it doesn't have anything to
do with what we know as the mcu except
it is like part of the story oh this
happened in their history so the fact
that it's in the marvel universe is like
a big heavy weight towards the story yet
not actually showing
any of it yeah the eternals is one of
those things that just didn't never
needed to exist
sadly yeah it just doesn't do anything
for the whole marvel universe like what
piece do they really play
like they're just the overlords that
just watch [ __ ] that goes down until
this very specific thing has to come and
then they step in then what's the point
of this i don't need you here you don't
you don't add to any of the other
characters you don't add to the universe
that's why i was just like click i don't
need to see this the problem with having
those kind of characters then then you
take away from the x-men who are to come
yeah because they have all the same
[ __ ] powers yeah you know like then
what's what's the deal and apparently
they're supposed to be god so they're
supposed to be what just 10 times
stronger than them right yeah then
what's the point of that yeah
where you been yeah we really needed you
yeah that whole time yeah when kyle
rittenhouse was out there just
could have stopped him say hey bro just
go back home oh my gosh where were you
you know when genghis khan was like
yeah in the earth
they're like okay okay
you know
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i hope you
enjoyed that review of one of my
personal
um just
terrible terrible picks for marvel films
like i just dislike this one so much and
i watched it twice
so and i do it for you so you had to
make sure i had to make sure
well i just had to go over the stuff
because
if you saw my face when i watched the
film the first time it was like this
why like why is this happening it's
always what
what
the whole time and so i'm like okay i'm
gonna watch and then kind of like take
mental notes this time yeah so there was
a second time was a lot of pausing i was
like pause what the [ __ ] why yeah i did
a lot of rewinding to be like am i
missing something
did i miss like i kept rewinding the
part where america got the courage to
fight yeah and and control her powers
i'm like wait when did it come to her
though i kept like i just missed it i
don't know you're gonna kill me i
understand it's okay no i believe in you
all right
[Laughter]
and geniusbrain every sundays at 12 p.m
is there if there's another film that
you guys want us to review let us know
in the comments uh doctor strange
madness multi whatever [ __ ]
multiverse of men multiverse of madness
was the one that you guys wanted us to
review so we did i didn't want to cause
i [ __ ] hated the film a lot but we
did anyways so let us know what your
thoughts were on the film what's the
next film you want us to review and
we'll go ahead and talk about it again
and until then we'll see you next time
peace